[Music]
on this friday night russian forces
advanced their attack on western ukraine
multiple missiles near a city seen as a
safe haven and the civilians getting a
crash course on combat if this fight
happens this will be their last fight
two super powers and a united plea for
peace
the high-stakes talks between the u.s
president and china's president a key
russian ally
young innocent lives upended by war the
resilience of ukraine's children
and canada's alarming rise in hate
crimes i was spelled on by a white man
what's stopping victims from stepping
forward
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight tracy tong
the ukrainian port city of mariupol has
been left in ruins much of it now
unrecognizable
russian forces have encircled the city
and there are reports of gun battles in
the streets as residents shelter in
bunkers even they aren't safe from
russia's bombings president vladimir
zolensky says more than 130 people have
been rescued after an airstrike hit a
theater sheltering civilians earlier
this week he says hundreds are still
trapped under the rubble including many
children
good evening and thank you for joining
us more on the situation in mariupol and
the ongoing rescue efforts in a moment
but first the scope of russia's
offensive is widening from the black sea
coast to the western city of levive
where a russian airstrike broke through
ukraine's defense system and hit an
airport
ukraine's capital was also the target of
more russian strikes
kiev emergency services says at least
one person has been killed and several
more injured we have team coverage from
on the ground in ukraine tonight with
jeff semple and mercedes stephenson
and we begin our coverage tonight in la
vie mercedes the city has been a
relative safe haven in ukraine since the
invasion began but that changed today
take us through what happened tracy at
about 6 a.m we started to hear air
sirens over the city and that's when
four cruise missiles launched from over
the black sea landed at the
international airport here in la vie
they struck an aircraft repair facility
they missed the runway the control tower
as well as the terminal and thankfully
there was only one person injured in the
attack they are in moderate condition
according to ukrainian authorities there
was two more cruise missiles that were
shot down by air defense systems that
did not manage to reach their target but
obviously this is a significant
advancement in the war west leve has
been as you mentioned a relative safe
haven and obviously if it is now
becoming a location for russian strikes
this would be the second one in under a
week the last one having been on sunday
and it killed more than 35 people that
is raising concerns about what it means
for the relative safety of western
ukraine and there's certainly
expectations that there are likely to be
more strikes against critical
infrastructure in this part of the
country and around levi that's something
that we were hearing from ukrainian
officials earlier today that they are
saying this is war and they are prepared
for more strikes like this that could
happen at any time
so what is the mood like among residents
there today who are now seeing the
potential for escalation on their
doorstep
well it's a really interesting contrast
because on the one hand you have a busy
european city where people are going
about their lives they're in restaurants
they're having coffee at the same time
there is a curfew and there is real
concern that there could be strikes here
there's a very large number of
internally displaced people who have
come here with their families who did
not want to separate with women and
children and the elderly going over the
border and men staying behind to fight
so this has sort of been a last
stronghold here it is a humanitarian hub
where there is a lot of humanitarian
assistance that is pouring in and also
of course we're very close to the polish
border only about 70 kilometers away and
that is where military support has been
coming in as well authorities here say
the strike on lev shows that russians
are in fact targeting civilian areas
that there is not a military base in
this city but it's certainly a feeling
of calmness but at the same time the
possibility of another imminent strike
now that it seems like this front is
opening up
mercedes stephenson and leve ukraine
thank you and stay safe thank you
now the question of whether to stay or
flee is becoming more pressing right
across ukraine for several days the
ukrainian government has said the port
city of odessa would soon become a
target and as jeff semple reports
russian forces now appear to be closing
in
if faced with the decision to flee or
fight this group has chosen the latter
ukrainian civilians receiving a crash
course in war odessa ukraine's third
largest city is in russia's war path
with its forces 100 kilometers away
these lessons are offered for free by a
military school since russia's invasion
in response to overwhelming demand there
are
very many people
who want
who consider
protecting their homes
their country their city this instructor
is a retired i.t consultant who took up
recreational shooting as a hobby a few
years ago can you teach them to defend
themselves against
a trained russian very difficult
question
this is something that everyone should
decide for himself
but i think that many of these guys
understand that
if this fight happens this will be their
last fight this married father of two
young children is receiving the training
fighting aged men aren't allowed to
leave ukraine and he says his wife
refuses to leave without him it's hard
we are ready to fight for our families
that fierce resistance might seem
surprising from a city once considered
one of ukraine's most moscow-friendly a
russian-speaking population and
centuries-old cultural connections
addressing a rally vladimir putin said
his so-called special military operation
is liberating ukraine's russian-speaking
population from a nazi genocide
in ukraine but as he spoke protests
broke out in the russian-speaking city
of kursan
against their new russian occupation
these claims that russian speakers are
under threat in ukraine are complete
lies and propaganda odessa's mayor told
global news a remarkable rejection of
putin's narrative from a politician
who's faced criticism in the past for
having close ties to the kremlin i think
that
putin is the biggest uniter of ukraine
this international relations expert says
putin's aggression has turned ukraine's
russian-speaking residents against him
in three weeks the city has become
blanketed in ukrainian flags including
this one on a monument of the city's
russian founder catherine the great it
cannot last like this anymore after he
invaded ukraine after he started to kill
ukrainian children
in the russian language cities the big
mistake is to think that russian
language
is somehow defines the belonging to the
russian state when asked whether she
would be willing to leave or accept
russian rule this russian-speaking
political expert is overcome
painful
moments like that one are so common here
we can be speaking with someone even
casually on the street when they're
suddenly overcome with emotion
a city on edge it's residents bracing
for the fight of their lives
tracy
jeff semple in odessa ukraine thanks
jeff
[Applause]
putin's rally at the packed moscow
soccer stadium marked the eighth
anniversary of russia's annexation of
crimea
he framed that military offensive as an
act of liberation and used similar
language in an attempt to justify his
current war on ukraine
extraordinary
putin vowed russia would prevail in what
he called the special operation in
ukraine
the address was carried live on state
television though programming cut away
briefly a spokesperson has since said
that was an error
the southern port city of mariupol is
completely surrounded and cut off from
humanitarian aid or escape that is
slowing efforts at that theater
destroyed by a russian missile on
wednesday
130 people have been rescued but more
than one thousand are believed to have
been sheltering in the building's
basement here's crystal gamansing with
survivor stories
the theater basement was supposed to be
a safe place now potentially hundreds
wait for rescue under the rubble two
days after a russian missile strike
mariupol is a destroyed city but is
being bombarded relentlessly and cut off
from aid
bodies still remain in yards and on the
streets
it's a horror what for
tell me what for what are we guilty of
it's not just in the south where the
attacks are shattering lives
see the missile hit our building
all apartments are totally destroyed i
do not know where i'm going to live now
where i'm going to work
i don't know to carry on living
ukraine's armed forces officials say
russians are trying to increase their
presence around the capital missile
strikes continue to be fired in and
around kiev many are intercepted still
dozens of residential blocks have been
hit the damage
almost can't be measured life is getting
lost
not just the infrastructure life is
getting lost
marijuana
butcher
life is destroyed and taken children are
getting killed families shared their
experiences with journalists friday all
had harrowing tales of escape and fear
for those left behind there were those
russian tanks and you know i said if
they don't let us through we prayed god
to get through and when we reached the
roadblock their checkpoint we were
stopped and they lined us up and we
looked down because we thought maybe if
they don't like us they will start
shooting us so many right now across the
country are weighing the risks of hiding
versus fleeing and if they get to a new
safer location in ukraine
how long will they have before the
fighting is at their heels once again
crystal gomanson global news
london
the world food program issued a stark
warning about ukraine's food supply
chains today saying they are falling
apart collapsing as key infrastructure
is destroyed
the country's food supply chain is
falling apart
movement of good has slowed down due to
insecurity and the reluctance of drivers
to drive to places like nepro
let alone mario pool
officials say mariupol is running out of
its last reserve of food and water and
that u.n aid convoys have been unable to
enter the city
u.s president joe biden spoke with
china's president this morning about
what's happening in ukraine the video
call came amid concerns china could be
thinking of backing russia in the
conflict by providing either military or
economic aid as heather yurix west
reports the u.s is hoping to stop that
at all costs
they lead the two most powerful
countries in the world and for close to
two hours joe biden and xi jinping spoke
via video link about one thing
the u.s president making it crystal
clear any move in support of the russian
invasion would not be tolerated china
has to make a decision for themselves
about where they want to stand
and how they want the history books to
look at them and view their actions for
weeks china has stayed on the sidelines
refusing to condemn the actions of its
economic ally and security council
partner but after friday's call china's
state news agency reported president xi
told the u.s president the ukraine
crisis is something we don't want to see
adding that as the world's two largest
economies we must shoulder our due
international responsibilities and make
efforts for world peace i do think that
it's an opportunity also to be a
statesman for xi jinping who has
complained that china has been held back
on the international scene but china
could benefit from the conflict as well
particularly if nato members and their
resources are distracted from chinese
activities in the indo-pacific a chinese
aircraft carrier sailed through the
sensitive taiwan strait just hours
before the leaders met china will have
to do the cost and benefit analysis very
carefully if his association with this
military adventure by kremlin is much on
the cost is much greater than the
benefit of this association that china
would really have to think twice
president biden will next join nato
country leaders for that special summit
in brussels where poland's prime
minister is expected to seek support for
a peacekeeping mission into ukraine one
that would see armed nato soldiers
deployed into the country in order to
accompany humanitarian aid tracy
heather urix west reporting in
washington thank you
the rising number of racist attacks in
canada coming up what victims of hate
are being urged to do
china's government plans to stick with
its zero covid strategy as the country
deals with its largest outbreak since
the pandemic began that means lockdowns
for tens of millions of people
along with multiple rounds of testing
travelers arriving from overseas will
still need to quarantine for up to three
weeks the country has seen 15 000 new
cases this month
china's official covet 19 death toll is
about 4 600 the vast majority during the
initial outbreak in early 2020
statistics canada has released alarming
numbers showing a surge of hate in this
country the government agency says
police reported hate crimes increased by
37 percent during the first year of the
pandemic and those targeting east or
southeast asian people went up a
staggering
301 percent
and as dan spector reports these
incidents are escalating at a time when
overall crime rates are trending
downward and a warning some of the
content in this story is disturbing
i was um spelled on by a
white man walking toward me who also
made some racial and sexual comments
vancouver's trixie ling says she was
assaulted in may of 2020 because she is
an asian woman become the model minority
but yet we have this illusion of
belonging but really at the end we are
still very uttered
according to new data released by
statistics canada the number of hate
crimes reported to police in this
country increased sharply in 2020 the
first year of the pandemic to the most
ever recorded hate crimes against black
canadians nearly doubled while those
against east and southeast asian
canadians quadrupled not only counts
cases where victims came forward i think
that the
pandemic has
exacerbated
the whole phenomenon last year in
montreal this man made a threatening
gesture at an asian woman he was later
arrested this person was caught on video
verbally abusing an asian man at a
quebec grocery store earlier this year
because of you chinese people not
surprising the hate crimes have been on
the rise for years this as overall crime
rates went down 10 percent it is a
national issue almost all provinces saw
hate crime numbers rise stats canada
says the biggest increases were in nova
scotia british columbia saskatchewan and
ontario 84 percent of reported hate
crimes take place in cities
the actual rate of hate crimes in canada
is far higher but
the vast majority of them don't get
reported to police lack of trust in
police and community language barriers
are just a few of the reasons more
people don't come forward trixie ling
did report her incident to police no
arrests were made but she wants to
encourage others to speak up the
anti-asian hate continues because
systemic racism continues so that's why
it's important for us to continue
speaking out a spokesperson for the
public safety minister called the spike
in reported hate crimes alarming and
said a new national action plan for
combating hate is in the works it will
include
strategies and new tools and training
for police dan specter global news
ottawa
cosmic close call ahead the asteroid
that caught earth off guard
[Music]
you're watching global national
[Music]
an unusual sight in venice the historic
canals that wind through italy's lagoon
city were almost empty yesterday an
extreme low tide left gondolas and small
boats beached venice is known for its
delicate balance between low and high
tides but factors including climate
change and rising sea levels have made
the fluctuations more drastic than ever
before
high ocean temperatures are putting
australia's great barrier reef in peril
once again
the reef is suffering from severe coral
bleaching according to a new report from
the marine authority that manages its
ecosystem unesco is also set to consider
downgrading the reef's world heritage
site status because of the damage it has
suffered from human-caused climate
change
another bleaching event in 2020 left
two-thirds of the reef's coral damaged
and there are no reports of damage after
an asteroid was spotted speeding towards
earth last week with very little warning
the asteroid named 2022 eb5 was first
detected just two hours before it
entered earth's atmosphere on march 11th
an astronomer in hungary raised the
alarm
the near earth objects coordination
center later calculated its orbit
showing it had a 100 percent chance of
impact
the asteroid wasn't detected sooner
because of its small size only around
two meters long about as big as a fridge
and because it was moving so fast at
almost 18 kilometers a second
experts believe the asteroid burned up
somewhere over western greenland and the
coast of norway
children in war next the sadness and
resilience of young ukrainians caught up
in the conflict
[Music]
it is hard to ignore the suffering of
the people of ukraine but imagine seeing
the horrors and hardships of war through
the eyes of children forced to flee
their homes and everything they've ever
known
yet the resilience of some of the
youngest ukrainians affected by brutal
conflict is not only inspiring it's
raising hope mike draulie has some of
their stories
there's no fear in the eyes of valeria
the five-year-old ukrainian who until
recently had known only joy in her life
with dreams as big as the 45 meter photo
of her unfurled this week in levive
supported literally by dozens of
ukrainians
her picture has now become a symbol for
her country's resilience
of course we know now how so many dreams
are being shattered yet within the
nightmare that's unfolding the strength
of the child refugees has been as
heartwarming as it is tragic
the teachers at this german school were
devastated to see how so many kids were
in need of help yet the families
arriving were so thankful so kind it
raised their spirits
this school director says once he saw
the children in the playground he
realized that's exactly what they needed
so they let them play
classes could wait
fortunately it takes a lot to extinguish
the innocence in a child but that
doesn't make it any easier for mothers
like elena who escaped to poland her
young son wants to return home but not
before elena gets rid of the monsters
waiting there
if only it were that easy
eventually the truth will find them how
can it not the weight of the war should
be on the adults not kids like the one
this senior citizen in moldova has
agreed to shelter
as maria says we're all human beings and
no one reminds us of that like the
littlest ones microlight global news
toronto
and that is global national for this
friday night i'm tracy tong as resilient
as children can be sadly too many won't
make it through this war we leave you
tonight with this heartbreaking and
powerful memorial
109 empty baby strollers were put on
display in la vie today each one
representing a child killed in ukraine
now that number is only according to
what ukrainian officials can confirm so
far the real death toll is likely far
higher
thank you for being with us take care
[Music]